Thanks so much.
I'm incredibly honoured to be here.
Today I'm talking about formalising former
right on the web.
Let me give context who I am.
I'm in Austin Texas, a JavaScript developer.
I've been working with Node.js for five years,
making websites and applications for just
about all my life.
I have an enormous amount of passion for distributed
systems and peer-to-peer technology.
I think they are technically fascinating but
there's an incredible potential in these kind
of technologies that haven't been leveraged
in the web, so that is what I pursue a lot
in my daily life.
I was one of the people who helped start the
secure scuttlebutt project which is a secure
peer-to-peer network.
I spend my days now working on the Beaker
browser.
It is an experimental peer-to-peer web browser.
We want to see if it is possible to let users
publish websites without having to use servers
at all.
We want to see if you could have a button
perhaps if the browser, you can click that,
then public the site from your laptop or a
mobile device, and then you don't have to
worry about operations and things are much
easier for you.
Curious to hear how that works, you should
listen to Tara Vancil's talk tonight.
What I'm going to be talking about is a little
bit about animates us to work on this project,
why we care so much about this idea, and we
think it can have a positive effect on the
web.
Now, we are huge advocate for the open web.
I think it's incredible that we have this
shared platform that's not encumbered by patents
or licences, and it isn't owned by any one
corps ratings, but lately the web has been
struggling with systemic problems.
Issues with things like bullying, harassment
online, misinformation campaigns that affect
our elections, and infringement of personal
privacy, and honestly, the list goes on.
Now, I think in a way, all of these systemic
problems stem or have some kind of relationship
to one basic question, and that question is:
who is in charge?
I don't mean this in a petty sense like who
happens to be the market leader from one moment
to another, but in a profound sense: who has
the authority to govern or communities and
our applications, and our online lives?
More importantly than that, perhaps, what
gives them that right to be the people that
govern our experiences?
On top of that, I think we also should understand
what kind of rights we have as users.
What rights do we have to control the software
we use?
What rights do we have to control the algorithms
that affect our perception of the world.
What rights do we have to control the moderation
policies that affect these issues that affect
us every day?
And so, you can talk about political rights.
In fact, there's been amazing work with the
GDPR, but there's something else, a kind of
right that emerges, I believe, specifically
from the technical design of the web, and
the architectures of networks in general.
And this technical right is derived from what
everybody is able to do.
So that is the right that we are going to
be talking about here today.
Now, I think it is important that we go through
some of the stuff that is the problem right
now which means we are going to have to go
through some offensive content — I tried
to censor it a little bit.
It's kind of annoying.
Let's talk about harassment.
Well, mostly talk about Twitter, but Twitter
of course is not the only community that has
this problem.
Here is Susan Fowler talking about anti-Semitism
filling her notifications.
Lately, Jessica had a death threat.
She had to struggle a lit bit to get Twitter's
moderation teams to take it seriously.
You don't have to go far to find this kind
of stuff.
I don't think this is news to anybody.
The internet is full of trolls, right?
The running joke at this point is that Twitter
is a cesspool.
Well, you could say that this is just how
it goes.
We should develop a thick skin, and perhaps
this kind of behaviour is just the cost of
free speech.
Perhaps that's the case, except that I'm beginning
to believe that this kind of behaviour is
affecting our culture, and our political systems.
I don't think I'm the only one to think that.
At the end of last year, Reid Hoffman weighed
in on this issue, how he would save the problems
of hate speech, abuse on our social media
platforms.
Reid Hoffman is the co-founder of LinkedIn.
In this interview, he gave his prescription,
and it was this: these are private businesses.
All these social media platforms are private
businesses, and they can set policies about
what kind of behaviour they expect from their
users, from their participants on the platform.
The metaphor he uses it's like a hotel or
restaurant.
You can set a policy, no shirt, no service.
The same thing here.
Project a more opinionated view about what
kind of speech is permissible on your platform.
That's what he is putting out.
Now, to some degree, I think he has a fair
point.
But what he is suggesting really highlights
what I think is kind of a constant probably
with how the web works.
It kind of highlights how we are stuck between
a rock and a hard place on this matter.
Because, on the one hand, I'm not the sort
of person who is animated by concerns about
censorship.
That's not my day-to-day.
My concern is more about bullying or death
threats to somebody I love, or misinformation
campaigns that might affect the elections
in my country.
That bothers me a lot more.
At the same time, I think you can't ignore
the fact that we had a very serious conversation
about the possibility that Mark Zuckerberg
could run for president.
This guy runs one of the most powerful information-sharing
platforms in the world — over 2 billion
users use Facebook to get their daily news.
So the idea that we at this juncture would
start to ask corporations more proactively
to police our speech is I think a slightly
bad idea.
So it seems like we're stuck between these
two options.
On the one hand, you have trolltopia where
everything is permissible, and, on the other
hand, you have a corporate hegemony where
speech is being policed by big businesses.
There ought to be something in between this,
something driven perhaps by users.
Yet it's not there.
Assess it happens, Mark Zuckerberg is not
particularly interested in Reid Hoffman's
suggestion.
He's extremely adamant that Facebook is not
a media company.
They're just a tools company.
If they were a media company, they would control
what kind of media is put on Facebook.
That's his point.
That's not their job.
He says this because, to be honest, he want
Facebook to be popular.
As soon as they start getting into these hard
decisions about what sort of behaviour is
per missable, they get into partisan fights
and using losers because they are seen as
biased.
This sort of dove-tails nicely into a conversation
about misinformation.
We are still in our systemic problems of the
talk here.
Let's talk a little bit what happens in the
2016 American election.
This is a Washington Post article and we will
go through some of the ads that were run illegally
by a Russian propaganda arm using Facebook's
ad-targeting platform.
If you were opposed to Muslim immigration,
you get this law from this Russian propaganda
organisation saying Shari'ah law should the
not be debatable.
If you were a Christian Conservative, you
got Jesus arm wrestling the devil, and if
Clinton won, the devil won the election.
If you were a southern conservative, you got
a fake tea-party endorsement for trump.
If you're an LGBT supporter, you got this
ad against the west borough Baptist church.
If you are were a Hillary Clinton supporter,
you got — the strategy they were pursuing
is getting to you click like, because then
they could push more propaganda to you.
The strategy was to strengthen trump's base
and divide Clinton's.
There is a lot of examples of what happened
and what went wrong in the 2016 election with
misinformation.
If you want more, look being at Reddit, and
Twitter has its own problems.
The next to fit in with the time I have was
important to illustrate because it cuts to
the heart of how this sort of stuff happens.
That's this one: this is an article published
by ProPublica last year.
There's an advertising demographic on Facebook
of Jew-haters.
You could target them with your ads.
It was apparently 2,274 people who put this
as their field of study.
Now, I don't know if they thought they were
being funny or being serious — it doesn't
really matter.
But, somehow, Facebook's algorithms picked
up on this and made it a group you could advertise
to.
I want to point out the UI element underneath
there.
Yes, I think so.
Okay, why is this happening?
Is Facebook intentionally setting out to collude
with the Russians, to mess with our elections
in America?
Is there some Facebook employee that is adding
that Jew-hater entry into the database?
I don't think so.
I don't think that is what happened.
I don't know, but I doubt it.
What I think is happening here is the same
thing that happens with every Silicon Valley
company trying to achieve enormous amounts
of scale: they're just using algorithms.
They're accepting user data without considering
just how problematic that user data can be.
This is a screen shot of YouTube.
David Hogg is one of the Parkland Shoot be
survivors.
He survived a high school shooting.
He decided to become vocal about his opposition,
or his support, rather, for gun control.
People who didn't like his politics decided
to spread a conspiracy theory that he's a
paid political actor, a crisis actor.
And so I guess enough people searched for
that on YouTube because that started to show
up as the only thing when you type into his
names that you should look into him being
a crisis actor.
It is a combination of these algorithms, and
then, what I could only describe as I suppose
the political weaponisation that is occurring
on the web, and will continue to occur, because
these platforms have the power to push an
agenda.
And every time you have one of these algorithms,
that blindly trust user input, that's another
vector.
It's another opportunity to push propaganda.
Okay, these are problems.
They're problems in how we govern our communities
online.
And, when you see problems like this, you
naturally have to ask who is in charge?
Whose job is it to solve these kinds of problems?
And I think this is where we see technology
and civics collide in an incredibly specific
way.
Because, we are talking about the system of
authority, and the system of governance.
Whose job is it to maintain these communities
online?
If you look at Reddit, it's ostensibly designed
to be a democracy.
In fact, it's probably one of the most democratic
websites online.
The users submit stories and vote what shows
up on the front page.
It is great.
But if you actually look at the civic structure
of Reddit, it is not actually a democracy.
It is actually more like a monarch can I because
you have the — monarchy, because you have
users submitting on comments, and above that,
you have moderator users, and they have the
power to remove content and users, and things
like that, and on top, you have the Reddit
staff who are basically the kings of this
community.
They have total control.
They can change the code, they can change
the data, they can do anything.
And, in fact, they highlighted this about
a year ago when the CEO of Reddit decided
to jump into TheDonald and manually edit some
of the users.
He trolled the trolls, right?
He figured it would be funny.
If you don't know how websites work, you might
be shocked to realise that somebody on the
Reddit staff can change people's comments.
But I think probably most of us here are technologists,
and intuitively aware of course they can do
that — they run the server, right?
That dove-tails into this next question: what
is it about the web that makes it like this?
Why do the Reddit staff act as the king and
have total authority?
I think it flows directly from this thick
server design, the architecture of applications
on the web.
Fixed server is a technical term meaning we
put the business logic into the server, and,
as a result, all the authority.
If you diagram it, it looks like this.
You got the thick server up at the to be,
and you have the database in there.
You have all the code.
And you have all the authority placed in the
server.
And then you have the web browsers, the clients,
and you actually call them a thin client.
Thick server, thin client.
And the thin client is just a few of this
data, just a rendering of what is occurring
on the server.
Any time you want to do something as one of
the clients, you actually have to ask the
server to do it for you.
So all the authority lives in the server,
and, if you have any authority as a user,
you're borrowing it from the server in a way.
What is it about the web that makes it like
that?
Why are the servers king?
There is nothing in the nature of computers
that make it this way.
If you look at computers in a state of nature,
hanging out next to each other, look at a
server, you look at a normal desktop computer,
or a laptop, sure, the server is more powerful,
but that doesn't necessarily meaning that
the server ought to be king.
Server doesn't have to be in charge but that
is what it is.
Why is it that if it is not in the hardware?
The answer has to do with this.
It has to do with the specifications and the
standards that define the web — HTTP, HTML,
all the web APIs.
They encode this set of behaviours.
This is a very clear example of how technology
doesn't just interact with civics, but it
actually drives civics.
It defines what the civic structure of a community
is going to be.
In a way you could say that these specifications
are like a shared contract between us, or
perhaps even like a constitution.
Because they define how our online society
of computers are going to work with each other.
There's nothing in the hardware that does
this.
It's in the specification.
It's in the shared agreement, these rules
that bind us together and define how our computers
relate to each other.
It is a contract or constitution because it
is just an agreement between the devices to
follow these rules.
It is in the constitution of the kind that
these people made but the kind made by people
like this, the hackers that set the web in
motion.
They produce documents that look like this
but it produce specs like this.
There is a parallel there, because all of
our computers, everybody here, we use the
image tag.
That's how that happens.
So, when we ask what gives the server the
right to be king over our application, well,
the answer is that it's in the architecture.
It is how the web is designed.
Now, it is not just the authority model that
is encoded in these architectures, it is also
the individual capabilities of everybody in
the network.
What can my computer do on the web?
Those questions are answered in the specifications,
and this gets us back to that idea of a right.
What rights does my machine have?
What rights do the server have?
I'm going to try to give us a term here — an
ark technical architectural right, a right
that gives me on my device encoded in the
web, or in any network.
Let's go through examples to make it intuitive.
Here we have a local area network.
We will go with the natural design.
Everybody can connect to everybody else.
So we have Alice, Bob, and Carla.
Their machines can talk to each other.
You might technology there's a architectural
right in this design, a right for everybody
to connect to everybody else.
You might decide that Alice is more important
and you maybe can't trust Bob and Carla in
your architecture, so you could do it like
this where only Al-shortlist allowed to create
new connections, and Bob and Carla just have
to listen.
You have to do it this way but then you would
have two kinds of citizens — Alice who has
the right to connect, and Bob and Carla who
can't.
Let's look at another example of the internet.
The internet is like our land because the
internet has the same basic principle: everybody
should be able to connect to everybody else.
Should be able to connect to everybody else.
You could say that there is a right to connect
globally encoded in the design of the internet,
in the architecture of the internet.
Again, you didn't have to do it this way.
You could do it like China has done it — excuse
me, I just want to point out, sometimes, the
internet doesn't work quite so well because
there aren't enough IP addresses in their
firewalls.
That's what that slide is about.
You don't have to do it this way.
You could do it like China, set up a global
government firewall, or you could set up something
like a municipal server somewhere that you
have to talk to and ask permission to make
a connection.
That is how you could do the internet.
We chose not to.
We chose to make it so that everybody can
connect to everybody else, and I think that
is important.
It means there is a value set encoded in that
standard in all the standards that define
the web.
A right to connect globally.
It's not a neutral decision.
So we have an idea about how architectural
rights work.
Let's take a look at the web.
You might say there are two kinds of establishes
on the web, like we were talking about before:
the client and the server.
The client is your browser or user agent,
so let's step through some of the rights that
each of these citizens on the web has.
The client of course has the right to browse,
go from one website to another and visit content.
Of course they can do that.
Clients have the right to filter as well.
You can run an ad blocker.
You might call this a right to mutate because
you can run extensions and change things once
you receive them.
This is open to interpretation, but I would
say those are the two.
This is what a client is allowed to do on
the web.
Let's look at a server.
Servers have the right to an identity.
An accuracy, a .com.
Only servers have that on the web.
Browsers don't have addresses
or identified — you need to ask a server
to make an identity for you because they are
the only ones with the right to do that, that's
why I'm twitter.com/username.
A right to publish.
This is what a server is designed to do on
the web.
They're publishing that content.
That's a right that only the server has.
The client can't do that.
If I want to publish something, I either need
to be a server, or I need to ask a server
to do something, and that's why I do my tweets
on twitter.com.
Because they control the publishing, servers
have a right to moderate as well.
They can choose what they publish.
Sort of falls naturally out from having been
dominate right to publishing, and then servers
can also choose what they had they deploy.
They get to choose the data model, where the
data goes been when you look at this citizenship
on the web it's unsurprising that there is
an asymmetrical power here, not only do servers
have more rights but way better rights.
That's the hurry to describe how the web applications
work.
The clients are passive.
The best they can do is make a choice about
where they go.
When you're talking about these problems of
governance online, how do we solve these tough
questions about moderation policies and the
truth of information?
How can we make governance better?
How can we give new rights to clients so that
the civic structure is no longer being constrained
by the design of the web, and the architecture
can have a more perhaps even democratic design
in how it is governed?
Can we make it so that the client has the
right to publish instead of always depending
on a server to do it for them?
Can we make it even so that the client has
the right to having an identity so that my
personal identity is no longer tied to whatever
happens to Twitter?
Could we even give clients the right to deploy
the code so they can decide how their application
should work?
Now I mentioned at the beginning of that talk
that I work on peer-to-peer networks.
In this context, peer-to-peer networks really
fascinate me, because, unlike client server
networks, they connect nodes in a way such
that they have the same capabilities.
The rights are completely evenly distributed
in a peer-to-peer network.
That's implicit in the name — we're all
just peers.
I think that has an equalising force across
the network.
It would be easy in a way to make this talk
largely about free software because in a lot
of ways, it is deeply connected, this ability
to control our right to modify how the experience
works, but I actually think it is a little
bit bigger than that.
I think it's about our ability to decide how
code works as a community.
That makes it a question of civics, not just
free software.
Every time we ask Facebook to make a change
to their interfaces, it's kind of a big deal.
It requires those companies to take a risk
to potentially loose users, or change something
that's fundamental to their success in the
past, and, as a result, they might not be
able to make those kind of risks.
When users have the option to develop the
software on their own, to pursue their own
needs, problems, and idea, they don't need
to be afraid that it might hurt their bottom
line, don't need to think in terms of maximising
engagement numbers but can think about solve
their own problems.
As technologists, it is our job not to solve
problems for people but to give them the tools
to solve those problems so they can decide
what is best for them, especially in these
contexts of these global society the like
the web is.
I think perhaps it's easy to think of the
web as being fixed and a stable place where
we've experienced the full history of the
web but the web has only been around for 30
years.
What will the next 30 years be like?
Will we continue to use Facebook and Twitter?
Is it going to be the same governance model?
Still have servers as king?
Or are we as users going to be defining much
more of our experience in the future?
Think about it, 30 years from now, is it going
to be like this?
I believe in civic engagement.
I believe in all kinds — legal rights and
regulations are powerful, and I'm extremely
excited about what the GDPR will do for our
industry.
But the legal system is not our own option.
As people who shape technology, and shape
the web, we have powerful tools at our disposal.
Technology is not neutral.
It encodes a set of values, and, as a political
system, it encodes a set of rights, so it
will be up to us to decide what our online
civic structures will be like.
I hope you take this time to consider which
structures of power and which rights you're
enabling in the architectures that you build.
Thank you all very much.
[Cheering and Applause]